bill when we met with you at story Expo
2014 you talked about your job at
Safeway yes and you had a plan B it
sounds like should other people have a
plan B or maybe that wasn't a job it was
just no the day the day job was because
you got to pay the bills and you know
that was there was never the plan B that
was that was that was the you know you
got to do something to pay the bills but
but I think that that's important to
have your have the bills covered because
if you're this is the weird part about
being a screenwriter is you don't know
where your next check is coming from or
if it's ever coming and when I sold the
script that got to Paramount that got me
to Los Angeles in the first place I had
two years of warehouse pay and I ate it
up basically doing nothing no networking
no nothing and so by as that money was
running out I was like I need to sell
script tomorrow and I think that that
panic is not good for your writing that
if you're writing something there's a
great scene at Sunset Boulevard where
Joe Gillis our screenwriter hero goes
into mr. Sheldrake who is the only
person on the lot the Paramount lot that
likes his writing and is trying to is
trying to pitch this baseball story and
says that you know I sent you the the
treatment you guys read it you know I
20th Century Fox is really hot on this
but I can't just I just can't see Alan
Ladd playing this character or whatever
the deal is and so he brings in the the
script reader and she looks at her
coverage and she said this is the
terrible thing it's all it's a terrible
script she just basically shreds his
story in front of him and then says she
says this was written from hunger this
is somebody that was desperate to find
work not somebody that was writing from
their heart and I think that ends up
being a problem with a lot of people is
you can Los Angeles is an expensive
place to live
and screenwriting is a hit-and-miss job
that people think that I'm gonna write
me a script get me
million-dollar checks and you know find
me an underwear model and that's not the
way it works what it works is you come
here and you're Joe Gillis you're the
guy that you know the the finance agency
wants to repo your car you know you're
you're living in a crappy you know
apartment someplace writing and that's
the beginning of your career if that if
you have a finite amount of money if you
go I quit my job and I have this much
money when he gets to the end of that
money you stopped writing from the heart
and you start writing from that I need
to make money and then you become the
you write the hack that has no passion
that has no soul to it and it's crap and
people can read it and it's crap so the
plan B thing which it really isn't plan
B but it's something that's going to pay
the bills so that you can then focus on
writing the script so you know in your
year off time I think last time I talked
about the you know page a day ends up
being three scripts so when you're that
time before work or whatever your net
the stress is off I'm not I don't have
to write this script to pay the rent
that's due at the end of the month
instead I'm doing this stupid day job
that's paying the rent and if you can
find a good if you're living in Los
Angeles there are stupid day jobs that
are great day jobs and what you should
do is look at ways that you can get in
the business from the side door and I
did a script tip on this a couple of
days ago about the the people that luck
out in the business I have a friend of
mine dammit who was a personal assistant
to a movie star and dammit if he didn't
use those connections to sell a script
guess what that guy was a screenwriter
who needed a day job became the dog
walker laundry picker-upper all that
stuff for a movie star and probably got
you know did you paid crap money but
made connections you can be the you can
be a reader although a lot of those are
going to intern you can be a dog walker
I know you know these are this the
horror story that I know is I know a guy
who's a limo driver and never wanted to
be a screenwriter or a film producer
except now he's a film producer because
as a limo driver you pick up movie stars
and when you pick up movie stars you end
up with all there with connections and
so he basically took a bunch of movie
stars that he picked up in his limo put
him into a package found a script took
it to a real producer and basically now
he's a movie producer and you go that
you know that's outrageous but think
about as you're the the struggling
screenwriter if you're going to look for
a day job don't find the day job that
gets you no connections find the day job
that gives you some connections I though
I would not suggest being a set PA
because you work 12 hours that's in
parentheses or quotes air quotes only
because 12 hours plus however much they
get you you know but the that's there's
no time to write but you can be an
office PA and basically work eight hours
in an office and do some set work you
know you're doing things you're making
copies of scripts you're doing all kinds
of stuff that puts you in contact with
the director the actors etc so find if
you're here in Los Angeles looking for
the day job find the day job that gets
you in and you know there's there's
plenty of day jobs out there that can do
that
you